quanti bramano beasley prega lana
scherzava vuoto compì il tuo dovere da
ninja stupido pupazzo vai dentro bravo
così perfetto
ragazzi io e te dico qui staremo al
mondo un giorno vedere fa vedere che
siamo
tu sei sta roba sembrano essere
collegati in qualche modo ragazzi devo
aprire la porta non so come dinho sta
roba
a questo questa è la chiave di sicuro io
lo metto è poi non lo so dubito che sia
una chiave perché un cazzo 18 provava
proviamoci
il progetto ricordo di lei abbia aperto
la porta perfetto ragazzi mica siamo
degli in gianatti ragazzi sono veramente
contento che nel caso mi succeda
qualcosa c'è un pupazzetto sul quale poi
rapidamente veramente una sicurezza
incredibile comunque vediamo dissente le
prove dare di che si tratta perché non
ho ancora capito dove stiamo andando
troviamo un modo per uscire il quale
siamo in casa siamo in un posto
bruttissimo che bel posto reja dove
siamo
c'è una sesta nova il mio dio ci ha
pensato questi oggetti fluttuanti
sembrano dei ricordi forse il prossimo
lì dietro con le radici
non lo so ma non voglio scoprirlo perché
mi cos'è un pazzo al ragazzi al passo
più difficile che abbia mai visto questo
però devo completarlo perché mi piace ho
già ho già trovato un pezzo che sono
troppo bravo e suo gioco che non c'è
verso 11 ce l'abbiamo legato mi mancano
gli altri ancora d'affetto blocca si
giocavano la strada un quadro figli si
muove lega che questo era un quadro
animato bellissimo devono tipo entrare
dentro la super mario si
il fantastico ok noi dove siamo finiti
non so dove ma non importa l'importante
è che andiamo avanti anche perché mi
spiego niente di tutto questo sono un
deficiente io non ho parole comunque c è
un caffè giusto ragazzi ci sono i
cassetti negli alberi non mi faccio per
niente domande tanto ho capito che non
ha un cazzo di senso magari c'è una meta
però non ho ancora capito quale sta a
metà perché c'è un fuoco del babbo
natale sei tu e andiamo avanti intanto
mi sa che qualcuno è lasciato i
rubinetti aperti ma a me non me ne frega
niente passo lo stesso e la la mistica è
salve
buongiorno ventaglio non hai da di chi
lei sia però io le regalo questo diversi
piani che un mio perché ci sono giochi
ob eccola pezzo del puzzle perfetto ci
siamo ragazzi amore entrati dal 4 quindi
cioccio l'altro pezzo questo pezzo dove
andrà mai
sarà mica qui non funziona non so
risolvere i puzzle da bambini di due
anni
perfetto che anzi noi pensavo potessi
mettere qualsiasi parte lo inserisce lui
invece noto mi metto come nel punto c'è
un altro quadro di una tizia che beve
l'acqua dal pozzo e che poi si butta in
un fiume per è che non si è fatto i
capelli non so perché si sta entrando in
quadri a caso ma noi andiamo avanti tu
ridi stronz errori di pezzi di stronzi
non è un tocco dentro non entrò valente
invece poi entrò perché non so cosa
diavolo ci possa essere io poi sotto al
letto
reagan ho capito perché sto bambino vede
tutte ste cose strane perché beve come
non so cosa facciamo finta che la
bottiglia non serve a nulla
andiamo avanti usciamo di qua prima che
il voto [ __ ] perché ha buttato
degli stivali sotto al letto di chi sono
madonna è uno stivale grosso quanto me
ragazzi io non mi interessa chi è ma non
me ne frega nulla non apro piuttosto
bevo come mostro cosa ma non aprirò
quella porta da nessun costo ok permesso
non so chi abbia bussato ma non lo
facciamo ci domandiamo avanti lega prima
che succeda qualcosa di brutto
quel che buttano 26 qualcosa cos'è
qualcosa
non ti piace il cubo che ho tirato prima
bastardo era un cosa brutto facciamo
finta di non aver visto nulla andiamo
avanti
ok adesso so che c'è un tizio albero che
ci segue ma non so per jet che cosa cia
contro di me quella fare gli ho dato
anche un cubo stiamo uscendo
questi rumori mi invogliano uscire in
una maniera incredibile l'ultimo posto
in cui vorrei entrare sarebbe questo
però fa niente ritornato nel lago vero
bene un macello girare sto coso lega
perfetto anche se le tasse perfetto vai
vai vai e vivrai sì sì sì che siamo
perché c'è un tronco in acqua regalato
muoviamoci prima che succeda qualcosa
possesso rob ha preso una chiave di
qualcosa non so cosa ma va bene c'era un
tronco prima a caso ma fa niente ha la
chiave serve proprio sta roba perfetto
che ve la chiappa no perfetto guai a te
se spunti da qualche parte ti ammazzo ok
perfetto hanno ascoltato bene
questo pezzo a pezzo di albero che non
sei altro
se ci ho fatto io agli alberi che devono
tartassare i maroni così perché c'è
un'altra chiave da prendere perché mi
serve un'altra chiave non ho idea di
dove sia ma credo che sia per forza
quindi vediamo niente devo spostare
travi bene ragazzi mi sa che i
[ __ ] tutto giorno beppe è così
lurido spero di averti anche colpito in
testa cioè che ci siano altre altro boss
new folk
io vivo rosso io bere vodka sin da due
anni eccola la chiave la chiave perfetto
adesso ciò la chiave quindi posso uscire
ho invece sto qui a bere vodka come un
bravo bambino farebbe si può si può rega
ok secondo me mi sono solo ubriacato
alla fine allora facciamo così devi fino
a che non muori evita di mini a rompere
le palle a me ancora [ __ ] è di
pure tu non ti dimettere perché già
siamo in condizioni precarie
stronzo fuori non mi ha preso non mi ha
preso che lo vedi questo stronzo di
merda sporca
luca è un miracolo che non mi abbia
preso ma va bene così usciamo prima che
so ragazzi sono tornato qui non mi
chiedete come non ho capito nemmeno io
ma va bene non può non me non facciamoci
domande andiamo andiamo avanti perché
quel tizio mi stupri
ok no bene vai vai veloce se usciamo mio
dio che sei qui pezzente lo so e non
voglio neanche come dove sei dove sei
dov'è che è successo no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
[Musica]
no no ma [ __ ] apri apri apri apri
apri e veloce veloce veloce veloce
insieme si è ovvio santo dio mio sconto
può mai essere inquietante una minchia
di albero comunque abbiamo l'ultimo
pezzo del puzzle quindi vaffan cuore
tutto il mio amico bello lì credo che
non si ripresenti più perché mi sono
levato dalle palle non sono più nella
palude è sparito la mamma perché speravo
che perfetto il quadro sia aperto bene
allora non ci sono palloni qui però non
palude 9 ricettivi credo funzioni così
ora andiamo in quanto è no però che
palle che sei
non mi ha visto se mi ha visto e ho
visto i telefoni di me e mi ha visto nel
caso non ne foste accorti mi ha visto
non lo vedo più ma non mi interessa
andiamo avanti c'è questa loro basso ha
ancora vodka per bambino perfetto
ragazzi dove stiamo andando crudista
porta per l'amor di dio
chiude bene ok vediamo di chiarirci
prima a ok perfetto di qua dietro
sfalsamento no no no no no no non lo è
ma che cazzo è uscito non è uscito un
cazzo per uscito per niente via via via
apriti prego ti prego
sì sì sì no no no no no potrai a mi ha
preso e sei stronzo sei stronzo destro
ora vediamo di capirci un attimo perché
qui un casino apri apri veloce che era
già spostata la sedia quindi meglio non
è entrato più prima va rotto il cazzo
per un'ora e poi amo non entra il
prossimo ricordo dove hanno detto sì sì
sì sì riga ci siamo abbiamo 3
abbiamo tre su quattro è il tuo libro
scorsa libro che avevi preso all'inizio
kit e in aramaico tra l'altro ma va bene
voi millsap iniziato a scavare con il
sappia che cazzo di storia e regala
racconto io ho una storia c'era un
bambino incazzato e un albero che lo
inseguiva forbici ore per arrivare da da
quel punto di prima fino a qui non ci
posso credere quindi somma vino dovrebbe
mai vivere tutto questo va bravo e il
pezzo quanto sarà bello una volta usciti
da cui potremo giocare insieme tutto il
tempo guarda sono molto contento
pronunciò due joystick con la
playstation non solo 1 milioni mettere
sta roba qua dentro chiudere il coso ma
perché c'è solo sta scritto non si
capisce una sega vabbé non importa tanto
a lui che legge mica l'ho è di magari se
tu mi che siamo a mare a fare qualcosa
invece faccio tutto io combatto io
contro gli alberi che ci hanno le gambe
e tu che cazzo fai infine la mano nella
nel cosmo avvicinando sempre di più lo
sento si ne manca uno avrà così un
pensiero per te ma mia madre non credo
che sia qui da in tutto bene sono qui se
ti serve un abbraccio lo sai ma
[ __ ] stavo scherzando vieni qui
che sei mio amicissimo ciocco logici
morta quando vuoi io sono pronto siamo
tornati a casa
ci sembrava sempre a casa mia questa
credo però stiamo andando sempre più giù
quindi non penso proprio che ora ragazzi
direi che posso concludere qui
l'episodio e se il video è piaciuto come
al solito lasciato argomento mi piace
anche alla pagina di facebook e come non
i video tratte nella descrizione solo se
non che si discrete che noi ci mettiamo
nel prossimo video belle ragazze